figaro live bonjour on est en direct ce
matin pour vivre un événement
extraordinaire c'est l'un des plus
grands joueurs de l'histoire voir le
plus grand joueur de l'histoire c'est
lionel messi qui a signé hier au paris
saint germain pour une durée de deux ans
on va vous faire vivre cette conférence
de presse de présentation qui va
commencer à 11h à mes côtés sébastien
fédéral direct sport au figaro salue
sébastien bonjour ça va bien ouais ça va
très bien
n'hésitez pas à prendre tout cela y va
nous poser vos questions on va essayer
d'y répondre au mieux donc voila vous
n'hésitez pas dans les commentaires
youtube dans les commentaires de la page
du figaro n'hésitez pas à venir nombreux
à nous poser des questions on essaiera
de répondre à tout ça je vois que vous
êtes déjà très nombreux à nous suivre
sébastien ma première question c'est est
ce qu'on se rend bien compte de ce qui
est en train de se passer
lionel messier est officiellement un
joueur du paris saint germain moi je
sais pas si on se rend compte parce
qu'il ya encore une semaine ça semblait
totalement impossible en tout cas
personne parlait de cette possibilité
que lionel messi joue en france en ligue
1 au paris saint germain même le joueur
non envisageable l'envisageait pas du
tout c'était certain qu'il allait
continuer à rester barcelone depuis
c'est l'affolement le départ le départ
en pleurs en conférence de presse de
messi son arrivée à paris tout le monde
sur les réseaux sociaux qui suivaient à
son son vol qui cherchait à savoir
quelle heure ils arrivaient exactement
c'était un petit peu l'effervescence l'a
peut-être conférence de presse on va
enfin se rendre compte que lionel messi
est en france au paris saint germain on
a vu la vidéo de présentation qui a été
faite hier
c'est une réalité les messies change de
club pour la première fois après avoir
passé toute sa carrière à au fc
barcelone j'avais un statut je crois que
ces six ans 112 buts en 7 178 matches
avec le barça c'est tout simplement
hallucinant
comment un joueur comme ça pour réussir
à s'adapter au paris saint germain est
ce que vous êtes combien
inquiet pour l'adaptation pas du tout
sur son adaptation il n'y a pas vraiment
d'inquiétude à avoir en tout cas à mon
avis parce que d'abord il était très
désir à paris pas juste par le club et
les dirigeants mais aussi par par les
joueurs qu'ils ont souvent un petit peu
draguer un petit peu taquiné neymar qui
voulaient rejouer avec messi depuis très
longtemps quand même presque forcé son
départ au barça fin son retour au barça
pour rejouer avec messi verra-t-il ses
compatriotes dit il ya paredes et
surtout l'entraîneur mauricio pochettino
son compatriote aussi argentin qui était
très désireux de le revoir je pense que
son adaptation elle va se faire très
facilement que il ya un vestiaire quand
même fait de grands joueurs qui savent
qu'ils savent s'adapter qui savent
s'unir pour gagner les marquinhos mais
keylor navas lemond et sergio ramos
affaire très bizarre de voir messi et
ragondins et l'équipe qui ont été les
ennemis jurés pendant des années entre
le real et le barça mais sûrement sur
son sur son adaptation je pense que ça
va se faire assez facilement vous on a
beaucoup de questions sur sur la page
youtube on nous donne alors on va
revenir sur l'assurance respect tactique
un peu plus tard je pense après la
conférence de presse mais une question
rapide quelle place prendra messi est ce
que en rel di maria va être le grand
perdant finalement nous est arrivé de
lionel messi ça c'est un c'est un grand
débat sur comment comment jouer avec
messi parce que à voir mais si dans son
équipe c'est bien mais c'est pas un
joueur qui va qui va tout faire c'est un
attaquant pas l'attaquant qui défend le
plus au monde
déjà qu'il ya ma paie 10 bape et neymar
pardon avec keith avait pu être un sujet
la saison dernière la saison précédente
ça c'est une question comment les faire
jouer ensemble et qui sacrifiait dans
cette équipe il ya forcément des gens
qui vont se retrouver sur le banc qui
aurait largement la place dans le onze
de départ on peut imaginer que di maria
peut se retrouver sacrifier s'il faut
pas jouer un petit peu trop la taxe
notamment en ligue des champions on a vu
souvent le psg jouer un peu avec un
système en tout cas une composition de
l'équipe ligue 1 et une composition
ligue des champions on part du principe
que maps et neymar mais si ça ne va
jamais sortir du onze de départ à partir
de là les places vont devenir très très
chères en attaque et di maria risque
d'en payer le prix on a parlé de de ce
mercato c'est un jour amos qui arrivait
gianluigi de denard goma oui daldoul
achraf hakimi c'est un mercato master
class comme on dit de la part du paris
saint germain oui c'est un mercato
exceptionnel je sais pas si on si on
pouvait rêver mieux lionel messi d'abord
rien que lui c'était c'est plus que du
réel c sous un crachin du pgi rêvons
plus grands ils ont totalement exploser
leurs plafonds et sur le reste c'est un
recrutement peut être parfaitement
ciblée en tout cas achraf hakimi c'était
un des joueurs les plus courtisés au
monde à son poste il est jeune et a
encore beaucoup d'années devant lui car
milan as roma il a été le meilleur
joueur de l'euro ça fait des années
qu'il est courtisé un ac milan était
considéré comme un des meilleurs
gardiens du monde il a il a que 21 ans 3
ou 22 ans peut-être donc ce sont des
joueurs qui ont vraiment ans le temps de
voir venir et sergio ramos aussi c'est
dans l'optique de gagner la ligue des
champions c'est un joueur qui s'y
connaît qui peut apporter énormément de
choses dans le leadership dans le
caractère et qui en a encore un petit
peu sous la semaine sur le terrain c'est
un recrutement oui 5 étoiles en plus de
ça avec des indemnités de transfert à
part pour achraf et hakim est quasiment
inexistante on peut parler rapidement de
ça ne va pas rien coûté aux bons paris
saint germain après autant le paris
saint germain a quand même bien réussi
son coup financièrement on va dire oui
financièrement ce sont des de vrais
coups ce sont des joueurs en fin de
contrat donc il ya quand même des primes
à la signature à payer donc ce sont
quand même des montants assez important
quand même moins important que s'il
avait encore eu quatre années de contrat
qu'il avait fallu payer toute une
indemnité de transfert mais
financièrement le psg a aussi réussi un
mercato disons d'une grande efficacité
on a loupé drague axe qui nous vendent
justement par rapport à 2008 2 de l'as
roma il va y avoir une vraie grande
concurrence avec eller davasse comment
on arrive à gérer ce moment à ton avis
le parlement va réussir à gérer ça alors
là dessus moi je n'ai pas la réponse
parce que je n'ai pas vraiment le
souvenir de deux gardiens d'un tel
niveau qu'ils ont réussi à gérer une
concurrence
souvent c'est quelque chose qui a un nez
plus d'ennuis qu'autre chose en tout cas
ça a mis plus de pression sur les
gardiens que nécessaire il y aura
forcément un mécontent on l'a vu
d'ailleurs keller et navas lorsque
l'arrivée de donna roma a été officielle
il avait publié un message sur les
réseaux sociaux un petit peu
genre gens on entre un peu de m'oublier
qu'est ce que ça veut dire je viens de
faire une saison incroyable en ligue des
champions et c'est vrai il a été assez
contestable en tout cas personne se
disaient c'était un poste à renforcer au
psg maintenant il va falloir faire un
choix est-ce que le nain va jouer la
ligue 1 de la ligue des champions par
exemple c'est une possibilité ça s'est
vu je me souviens notamment au real
madrid avec iker casillas la légende du
real madrid qui avait été mis en
concurrence ça ne s'était pas très bien
passé son concurrent diego lopes n'avait
pas très bien assuré derrière les deux
étaient un peu instable et c'est
vraiment ça ça peut être un vrai casse
tête pour pochettino alors on à alexis
sur youtube qui nous demande si c'est
une bonne chose que lionel messi
prennent la place de di maria alors que
le club aurait pu prendre un joueur
comme paul pogba paul pogba est un très
bon joueur mais je pense qu'il ya quand
même une différence de coût entre lui et
le nahd mais si il ya une différence de
coût et aussi grenelle mais si à ce
moment là il est libre est ce que le psg
était capable de se dire non on laisse
passer me si on va se concentrer sur un
recrutement un petit peu plus ciblées ça
reste quand même lionel messi ça reste
l'un des sites n'est le meilleur joueur
de l'histoire et qui en est encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup beaucoup par vente
sur le terrain c'était difficile de
passer à côté on vous rappelle que la
conférence de presse de l'ump s'il va
commencer d'ici deux minutes a priori
s'il n'y a pas de retard on vous fera
vivre cette conférence de presse en
direct et nous on y reviendra un peu
plus tard en attendant est-ce qu'on peut
quand même aussi parler du poids qu'un
lionel messi sur le marketing d'un club
c'est quand même un poids lourd en terme
d'économie de de force d'attraction on a
vu ce matin déjà une queue et beaucoup
de beaucoup de gens qui étaient présents
pour acheter le maillot de messi bien
sûr en termes de marketing c'est c'est
peut-être ce qui se fait de mieux dans
le monde du football c'est un joueur on
critiquait beaucoup ce qu'il coûtait au
barça en terme de salaire mais il
fallait surtout pas oublier ce qu'il a
rapporté au barça en termes de
merchandising en termes d'attractivité
pour faire signer des sponsors à ce
niveau là mais si c'est une vraie
puissance surtout à paris maintenant
dans un club peut être un petit peu plus
bling bling que le fc barcelone qui est
un petit peu plus un petit peu plus dans
son coin qui n'est pas une capitale le
psg qui vend toujours ce côté un petit
peu avec avec ses stars
en termes de marketing un lionel messi
c'est aussi un énorme coup et lionel
messi y est on peut on avait une rumeur
ronaldo avant finalement ce sera pas
brutal de se tramer 6 avant que ce soit
les deux mais là quand même on va pas
trop rêver bah maintenant on a envie de
se dire que tout est possible
visiblement ce que lionel messi quitte
le barça et que sergio ramos quitte le
real madrid pour se retrouver ensemble
au psg voilà pourquoi est-ce que vous
donnez vous presque christian en inde où
ne devrait pas se rajoute à tout ça bon
l'appareil financièrement ça être
compliqué il va falloir peut-être un peu
dégraisser je sais pas si neymar mena
paix messi ronaldo pendant tous
coexister mais mais peut-être un jour
maintenant on peut en foot on peut se
permettre de l'imaginer après tout il ya
les notes grande question c'est l'avenir
de clénay mbappé qui a name bape et qui
normalement
arrivent ils arrivent à la fin de son
contrat dans un an il a un peu il
voulait attendre de prolonger il fait un
peu ils jouent la montre on va dire il
attendait du psg d'avoir des vraies
preuves que le club pouvait aller loin
là je pense que ça y est ce qu'on pense
que
ça va le faire pour lui là dessus en
tout cas son argument parfois c'était le
projet sportif qui n'est pas forcément
convaincus qu'ils pouvaient gagner au
psg sur ce mercato on peut considérer
que le psg a fait tout pour en tout cas
que c'est difficile pour bape et de dire
je ne suis pas convaincu
maintenant on peut aussi penser assez
raisonnablement que bp a de toute
manière pris sa décision qu'il quittera
le psg un moment donné qu'il jouera au
real madrid a toujours été le club de
ses rêves quand il était petit qui le
courtise depuis cinq ou six ans quand il
était encore à monaco on peut on peut
réellement raisonnablement penser que ma
paie quoi qu'il arrive quittera le psg
en tout cas là ça ne prend pas vraiment
le chemin d'une prolongation tout cas ça
n'avance pas on part sur l'idée comme
d'hab' et va passer la saison au psg en
fin de contrat qu'il quittera donc le
club librement qui sera un peu un coup
dur pour paris en tout cas un gros
manque à gagner maintenant paris va
devoir peut-être livre avec au moins ils
se sont assurés que derrière ils s'en
remettront peut-être un petit peu
sportivement avec neymar messi di maria
ils gardent ont quand même une équipe
pas trop mal sur le terrain ça va
effectivement faire du monde avait une
question pour déborder sur le terrain
caen qui va tirer des coups francs tu
vas tu allais penalty on à neymar messi
sergio ramos pour les penaltys comment
on va comment ils vont réussir à se
partager la balle on va dire sur les
responsabilités ça ça peut être très
intéressant effectivement on se souvient
que c'était entre neymar et cavani qu'il
y avait eu des conflits sur les tireurs
de penalty qu'une fois cavani il avait
tiré alors que neymar voulait tirer est
que cavani l'avez ratée et que ça avait
un petit peu se mêle à 10 la zizanie
dans le vestiaire entre mbappé neymar
aujourd'hui on est jamais eu de problème
pourquoi aussi parce que ce sont de très
bons amis ils s'entendent très bien en
dehors du terrain c'est le cas aussi
entrées de messi et neymar on peut
raisonnablement penser que ses joueurs
seront sans entendre de façon à ce que
l'équipe tire le meilleur d'elle-même
maintenant sur le leadership ça va être
aussi très intéressant parce qu'il ya de
grosses personnalités il ya de gros ego
en cette équipe mais je pense aussi que
ce ne sont pas tous les mêmes
personnalités les mêmes leaders lionel
messi est pas un leader très vocal c'est
vraiment un leader technique qui montre
l'exemple sur le terrain il ya des
leaders un petit peu plus vocaux comme
sergio ramos ou marquinhos par exemple
donc je pense que c'est c'est un
conglomérat des baux et de personnalités
qui peut coexister dans une équipe alors
que vous avez en ce moment même les
images devant le parc des princes avec
la foule qui attend lionel messi hier je
sais pas s'il est déjà arrivé mais en
tout cas la conférence de presse n'a pas
débuté elle devait débuter à 11h ça n'a
pas encore commencé on avait une
question justement parce qu'on parle de
ronaldo 2e alain qui nous demandaient
messi ronaldo dans la même équipe s ce
n'est pas une bonne et dans l'équipe est
ce que ce n'est pas un peu trop est ce
que ce n'est pas une bonne idée mais si
hier on a d'autres dans les limites
exactement si ça sera effectivement
assez vous pouvez être un côté un peu
excessif si on se permet de fantasmes
mais est ce que ce sont deux joueurs qui
peuvent qui peuvent jouer ensemble
surtout à leur âge ça aussi une donnée
qu'il va falloir prendre en compte on a
le dos aujourd'hui la 36 ans mais si
l'on à 34 est ce que ce sont deux
joueurs qui pourraient évoluer en
attaque dans l'année l'équipe sont deux
joueurs qui pourraient s'entendre en
tout cas sur le terrain qui pourrait se
trouver qui pourrait parfaitement
s'entendre ça y'a pas de problème mais
après ce qu'il faut éviter c'est ce que
devra déjà évité de payer cette saison
c'est d'avoir une équipe coupée en deux
ça a souvent été quelque chose qui
revenait avec paris parce que il y avait
ses attaquants stars qui devait assurer
aussi le repli défensif qui devait
assurer un certain équilibre
effectivement avec messi et ronaldo là
ça deviendrait très compliqué
ne pas avoir les joueurs d'un côté et de
l'autre sur le terrain ça sera déjà le
problème un peu du psg si jamais le bape
et messi neymar doivent jouer ensemble
ça ce sera justement des problèmes de
riches un peu de mauricio pochettino
c'est ça comment faire comme beaucoup
comment faire défendre toutes ses stars
au final on parle d'une d'une possible
défense à trois mares kings qui paye
mais ramos pour essayer de solidifier sa
est-ce que ça paraît une possibilité
crédible ce qu'il faudra aussi éviter ça
je pense que mauricio pochettino est
très au courant c'est justement encore
une fois d'éviter cette équipe coupée en
deux c'est de ne pas se dire je vais
rajouter des défenseurs pour équilibrer
le fait que j'ai plein d'autres accords
c'est que il faut pas que les défenseurs
d'un côté les attaquants de l'autre et
au milieu rien du tout sinon pg ne
ressemblera à rien en ligue des
champions et
n'aura aucun contrôle de ce qui se
passera sur le terrain donc ça c'est à
éviter il faut essayer de trouver
vraiment l' équilibre la bonne formule
pour que l'équipe soit cohérente et
qu'elles soient capables de jouer
ensemble et qui est vraiment onze
joueurs qui jouent ensemble dans la même
direction alors vous avez toujours les
images en direct du parc des princes
d'une aile mais s'ils devaient être
présents pour la conférence de presse à
11h il est 11 heures quatre un petit
retard a priori pour l'instant on va
voir ceci si cela dure mais on continue
à prendre vos questions si vous en avez
continué à nous les poser on avait aussi
une petite question sur comment est-ce
que messi est finalement arrivé au paris
saint germain on en parlait un peu à
vendre avant de lancer ce direct il ya
une semaine ça nous paraissait
complètement fou cette histoire oui tout
à fait c'était c'était inimaginable
la direction prenait clairement le sens
de une prolongation de contrat de lionel
messi au barça même avec une énorme
baisse de salaire de 50 % ça semblait ça
semblait ficelé maintenant il ya eu
différentes différentes choses qui se
sont passées notamment un accord du
championnat espagnol avec avec cvc qui a
donc racheté 10 % des parts de la lia ce
qui a un peu ce qui est un petit peu
bouleverser certains certains domaines
financiers pour les clubs espagnols et
le barça s'est rendu compte qu'en fait
ils ne pouvaient pas homologuer le
contrat lionel messi surtout que lionel
messi comme il était en fin de contrat
et qui n'étaient plus quitter un joueur
sans club depuis presque un mois c'était
considéré comme un nouveau joueur et que
si jamais on a enregistré son salaire le
plafond exploser totalement le barça
devaient largement dégraisser son
effectif avant ça donc le barça ne
pouvait plus prolonger ça a été un choc
pour tout le monde pour ça que lionel
messi tav a paru totalement ampleur
parce qu'il pensait jamais que ça
pouvait arriver et derrière le psg bat
en trois quatre jours a réussi le goût
de leur avenir possible alors que vous
voyez sur les images du paris
saint-germain de lionel messi qui est
dans les couloirs du parc des princes
avec sa femme ses enfants leonardo n'a
fait un travail fille ils vont rejoindre
normalement la salle de conférence de
presse on le voit en ce moment ils
arrivent et la conférence de presse
devrait bientôt débuter normalement il
devrait apparaître aussi sur le sur le
podium devant le club plupart des
princes pour voir les fans une petite
une petite question rapidement si on en
a eu est ce que le psg peut recruter
suarez qui seraient libres en 2022
imagine mans on sait l'amitié qui le lie
de la métier et luis suarez est ce que
ce serait possible c'est une question
alors j'ai perdu le pseudo de la faune
qui l'a posée mais voilà est-ce que
c'est ça oui parmi les rumeurs récentes
ci n'avait pas atterri au ps a parlé un
petit peu de la techno de madrid parce
qu'il aurait pu être très intéressés
déjà de rester en espagne et de
retrouver dans ses meilleurs amis dans
son bol de mil suarez maintenant est-ce
que luis suarez pourrait rejoindre le
psg en 2022 pourquoi pas si c'est un
joueur en fin de contrat le psg pourrait
tout à fait se positionner dessus il
aurait des arguments de réunir neymar
bbc suarez comme à l'époque du barça
maintenant c'est assez loin il y aura
d'autres choses à prendre en compte
effectivement si elle bat et s'en va
envisager que un attaquant un peu de
renault viendra reformer un trio on peut
l'imaginer on va vous laisser avec la
conférence de presse de lionel messi qui
écoute et de nasser el khalil fille et
on reviendra après cette conférence de
presse n'hésite pas à confier à poser
vos questions on y répondra aussi à la
fin
il
non
les semences
bonjour à tout bon jour à tous
le club est très heureux de vous
accueillir aujourd'hui au parc des
princes pour cette conférence de presse
historique organisée dans le cadre de la
présentation officielle de leo messi
vous aurez d'ici quelques instants la
possibilité de poser vos questions en
rapport avec l'objet de cette conférence
en français en anglais ou en espagnol
mais auparavant je laisse la parole aux
présidents du paris saint germain
monsieur nasser ali fille
bonjour à toutes et à tous
aujourd'hui je vous parlais anglais
parce que je pense hélas beaucoup je la
laisse par l'anglais aussi s'y met aussi
pour lio comprendre l'anglais par
les radios libres
se présente lui aussi à ce palais
saint-james en plein
meeting historique des progrès que la
photo
a dit non lieu il de holly football club
pour un sextoy vers l'andorre
de livres email photo paul magic puis
trouvant en zone à
et obélix ait un rôle important
dans cette guerre
amazing trois fois et what if you
jean-claude déclare deux phases
une phase i want it
offers de yahoo avec la ceni aux égos et
when people
cédric ndoumbe le clap hands up
project for
your
father projet ultime
fantastique joe biden à numericable à
défaut le gâteau sommeil team pour le
solde à l'extérieur de la centrale
l'autre vie vos vidéos n'ont pas
déclenché de nombreuses brochures
fantastique
l'hôte d'un coup vers match devient donc
un
livre au lit
working girl de
communication du montcel airbag et de
gatineau en dessous
highlight au
fait comment
le phosphore est
encore entre nos deux pays
les mots sont importants de phase
forward s'amoindrir next to me yvonne
l'autre office and i'm so i can après
grâce à notre avis très claire baude
estime m fantastique squat des vidéos
fargo
and amazing coach studio sur une mono 2
ps 1 nouveau en forme et risque de
baisse à nos distances sur lynx trouve
pas d alan wake longue en livre de speed
for you back office les eaux de
l'anglais au tout camion pour palais
saint-james à family un tuyau family on
a promis 5 ans et uk ns les vallées
alpines parle d'être mieux redit leur
ouvrir
février pour des motifs inconnus ou des
habits oncle
voilà
ce
que tu me fallait être ça me
met sa vie allait le voir c'est le
nationalisme et le ceram à 3 euros par
mois sur sa nièce est difficile quand de
détente était un peu tôt
noma kaka ne mangera car la féliciter
ces normes et multi sim arena - le
scénar et par un prêt sans intérêt ça
ramène de croquer j'ai passé château
rappelons qu est la taille du foot à
l'aboutissement premier degré ou d'amis
d'amis famille les amis
kentucky le tnp sarah entraîneur pour
que lentement la nasa et d'un contre
d'école comme accompagner la conagua
côté nico est un peu sa guitare est
amour et a pas
que restera apprécié ltée est le
narrateur clos pourquoi m tram et des
prix mérite sa lionne communiqué
barcelona
comme ces pensionnats et position le
rapide facile que ferait photos et une
tante au quotidien pour la situation
moins difficile à régler le manach l
estime et impressionnera leur assassinat
il traite en
lauragais rapide est en effet les
etarras 4 et le sauna communes chez cima
ghana tango et
luccioni la une la grinta des décès il
pourrait vraiment éclos parquet sanglots
ambitieux sa bo la
lipothymie que l'apprentissage et
tingwick rockets qui est à préparer au
pas pas un détail peut y aller porter
plainte et à reconsidérer ses murs et
ses écrits ses noces et ivan basso ses
galons de titulaire et il pourrait se
presser notre cloud à la guitare ou de
repos avant qu'on sait il qu'il aurait
serré la main des parties fines à la
cour ami
michel
hidalgo mass market et fait la fête à
m'énerver des indiens tels la série mr à
toi et tes sourires amos adamu timothée
et un
port polonais diop était clos
le pari somalie il fera sa part pour
être à kayes
merci nous allons passer à la phase de
questions réponses
oui bonjour lionel paris cité voilà
voilà alexis longtemps de life et quel
est votre sentiment à l'idée de jouer
aux côtés de neymar et qu'il ya des maps
et
la règle a fait l'essai à rome on a le
coup la communication
pour accompagner les iphone est apprenti
choqué que généralissime quoi rentrer à
solignac et sam et au futur état
couleurs et partez l'occ et l'ots kariya
et les mouches allusion aux mutilations
par un pétard a entraîné des coupes et
évoqué lors ya cinq ans quand la mairie
et 73 et l'hymne des
serments son ailier ripol fédérer de
torres
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour les hôtes de mixer verra
que du parisien bonjour bonjour
bienvenue à paris quand est ce que vous
pensez pouvoir discuter vos premières
minutes dans le championnat de france
la vraie canal au sein
de la vacation et mayumi palau
hrc mbia al thani great work côté nico
ne le sait
n'a prêté par art
seul un peu ces randonneurs mais bien à
quoi me prépare à un peu ça la classe
est alors possible
de voir alain péronnau scène deux
policiers donnent à la femme et à écrire
année il commence à saint-etienne des
canaux
un côté nicolas cia que c'est un momento
et l etat raymond comorienne
j'en à l'équipe bienvenue vous avez
parlé de votre tristesse de quitter le
barça vous avez parlé de votre joie
d'arriver à paris quelle est aujourd'hui
l'émotion qui est la plus forte sur ces
trois derniers jours les larmes la
tristesse ou la surprise et la joie de
voir un tel accueil
tendu comme passerelle est intime assez
mal après
le fn it et douloureux lyall moutien
pour rappeler aux frais
émotionnel si les cadres à la menthe et
au look et non comme eto'o car il y
passait pour personnifier quand il n'y a
pas là autres lots cie lucio napolitano
ait appartenu à connaître kabila à
meyrin partie familia il argué que tu as
moins me contenterai les tracas et
aurait fini tu es très malin mais pas ça
m compass importance à saint-aignan t il
aux frimas émile hagneré
lapokita comment com - rien n'a été
préparé par à
toronto et il en fut massimiliano
comment comme employé à carreaux
bonjour lio n'a certes nordine bouziane
al jazeera
président on le sait c'est ici c'est
paris on sait aussi que le rêve de paris
c'est toujours rêver plus grands
jusqu'au peuvent aller les limites de ce
rêve est liée aux biens mais lido
certainement vous avez vu que le peuple
parisien vous a répondu trois jours
peut-être plus il y avait des supporters
qui ont assisté jusqu'à 3 heures du
matin attendant votre avion quel est le
message que vous envoyez au peuple
parisien et tous les amoureux du
football en france merci
je pense notre notre objectif tout le
monde
connaît mon gars chaque match et
trophées ont toujours si notre objectif
on n'a pas changé bien sûr maintenant
avec avec le lieu où je pense on est
proche mais on n'est qu'à n'est rien
encore comme jeudi
2-2 puis
parce qu'en france je pense maintenant
besoin travail et ont besoin après
morgan échec match pour gagner trophy
ont besoin vraiment tout cet été gagnée
discipline c'est le plus important
comme nicolas catard à
la crème des salles et a commencé
la fia et fota
lannion
bonjour monsieur juste ici - voici
français les visions bonjour les eaux
bienvenue à à paris bonjour président
félicitations pour ce transfert
historique président beaucoup de
questions se posent sur l'avenir de
killian bape et après l'arrivée du
meilleur joueur du monde lionel messi
qu'en est il de l'avenir de quillan
papéa à paris
non seulement de le connaître la future
donc calé les parisiens des joueurs de
paris
qu'il y en a des très compétitive créé
la mentalité pour gagner il ya dix
publiquement les veaux un compétiteur
une équipe je pense maintenant on n'a
pas plus qu'embêté de cette équipe ça
veut dire et là bas ce cube pour
fêter quelque chose l'autre
fille voilà
on est heureux de leur effet et toujours
rien à vos quatre ligas de campeones et
carlo qui nécessite une équipe au parana
libanais
et
du monde il nous a étonnés et fully
appel à nous dresser l'opinion et tâche
est
difficile
la championne croquer
quel parent et amis le savaient et oui
oui celle qui t'a tout inside et ninon
et on ne dit pas ça dans le bourg
nous ne pouvons construire et où musique
et à la compétition
quelques
connaisseurs motors
la foire a
donné ce soir
c'est un peu la soirée
et aoc au
[Musique]
km2 et
brana mais croit pas ça ok la meilleure
équipe au monde à nos logiciels angola
zhang pas que la compétition est spécial
y est seul à 7 ans et sa compagne
qui est un monde là la guerre
bonjour nicolas paillardes infosport +
et canal plus ce qu'est ce que
représente pour vous le paris
saint-germain comment vous allez pouvoir
apporter toute votre expérience à cette
nouvelle équipe est président avec leo
messi maintenant au paris saint germain
est ce que le psg est favori numéro un
pour la ligue des champions merci
guillaume sciard important et temporaire
comme en
témoignent les poètes champions et je
vais mourir l'intérêt de mag ont
combattu simulation comme au ghana que
canon cas et voudrait c'est loïc rémy
aurait dit oui me soigne un pour aller
entre autres championnes et croquez la
loire idéal par un partenaire matthias
il pourrait par conséquent
je pense si on ne fait rien on n'est pas
très bonne équipe bien sûr aujourd'hui
on a gagné rien on a besoin vraiment
travailler comme je dis gagner chaque
match comme vous savez l'année dernière
on a jusqu'à la dernière du match
peut-être pas quels effets sur le groupe
state ses fautes mots on a dit leo c'est
vraiment c'est pas facile à l'ex
champion en vaut vraiment qu'un centre
et en bronze masques par match pour
aller la plaie la plus loin c'est sur
notre directement cache pas mais on peut
maintenant on a là
la ligue on se fait sur la ligue après
15 depuis 15 septembre on va rêver pour
la ligue des champions mais c'est pas
facile c'est pas s'effacer bourdy on est
faits vote mais on est on est on est
pour le club mais c'est sûr c'est notre
objectif mais un calme on est
là sur le terrain après on travaille
besoin de travailler travailler
et je vois in town espagnol hockey est
assez quattrone use only marc rubio des
barcelona part à 4 au deuxième rang des
locaux perreault décider qui est le
gardien parisse et le cloud comme bien
dodues pas ta mère dégardin finale de
champion's league et est et on a
decision to been paraît derrière et
paris saint germain par affichage et que
les ossis fdd citant bien fort qui et
comment ayez toujours l'aspect
relationnel ce qu'on est mal
l'importance des coûts fixes à réunir 10
pour les marques
wen a indiqué que ses commandes
tandis qu il ya entre les territoires et
au labrador la plancha ktiri comme l'a
écrit en terre c'est le lyonnais y est
une émulsion possible et conseillé le
critique aucun communiqué les croquer
que tantôt paris comme au chaud
beckham a remis mardi aux intérêts
d'état s'est par ailleurs elle a qu'a
raconté c'est un moment fort d'être
hariri le programme on ne pourra vous
conseiller de liam internet de la case
départ en lv3 lyonnais et ville marie
apparaît que le conapp appartenait
connaissez
vous n'avez et ce domaine
ils sont mous d'hsbc à paris qu'il était
loin
europe 1
hormis les matches de ligue des
champions que vous avez pu jouer contre
des équipes françaises qu'est ce que
vous connaissez du football français
parce que ça va être peut-être une
découverte pour vous qu'est ce que vous
connaissez des clubs ça va être autre
quotidien le championnat est ce que vous
connaissez des équipes parce que vous
connaissez des joueurs les rivalités
aussi qui anime notre notre championnat
la ligue française a
créé sur mutisme en
temps
de crise a été
mise à l allier
acquérir
des parts égales à la ligue ainsi que
contre
l'espagne en
fixerait est
alors de marsan qui
est
attiré par
[Musique]
ignace
heinrich ascos arrivé à nassimah et
je sens
une équipe compétitive pour le champagne
à la jambe pour crimes économiques
mais outre
qu'il essayait de compiègne d'or est
sorti au profit de travail et vos
témoignages
comment comme un clou il a annoncé sinon
à votre idéal pour une ligne d'eau à
celle ci machine à passes a paralysé par
la soeur linda
bollea barcelona que l'acea contraintes
et pendant ce point et il pourrait être
la race est moins
rare à la fois amicales que notre ami
c'est d'après
lé toulouse
19-9 president of je suis parti
c'est parce que si y'a que nous tournons
cabriès hallyday tout confort zone à
l'est à sa quille en l'air et a pas de
preuve en tout cas de léo que vous gavât
et los infantes y laissent des nuances
et les capitaux ce qu'on dit c'est aussi
soigner ça aura six abris aux pilos
sonia reconnaissent aux hyper précédente
et les probantes au coin des peines à
doha cas comprennent des requêtes au dos
et seau à placido possible à bléneau
colonard de coin de la pièce 10,6 alors
là pour des musées va la leo messi à
paris muchas gracias
balawi avait intégré
christiane hurle politique au niveau des
personnes
mais
manama est soumis ces pré sert comment
comment partita qu'on perçoit la série
thor et
il ne sait pas s'il est guéri
mais les
canaris et que llorente tarte au
maroilles pour
conseiller la
[Musique]
technique
de tous les ballons chauds barcelone
amazing scott and stay with a fairy tale
hausse +0
follow the hunting pays clés non vie
locale alors comme shopping ou shopping
our de ligue 1 bibeau sort à solazur si
dans trois ans au lieu d'un smic une
perte de capacité tout ça
[Musique]
you and me dennis dawson
on le dénigre fait
poser
des garde-fous déclare avec la crise
ringo balle très clairement comme chez
béliveau fruit des vignerons des
médicaments boss du canada pendant de
nombreux conflits ou encore morrow
céleri
et l'ensreg motors inc non mais avril et
30 à celui sous des tirs au but le 4e
match
[Musique]
déblaiement des trottoirs
côté nico et frechaut mutsch au panneau
signale la conversation les coins de rue
moquera possible et le primauguet qu'ici
vous fait peur la colère prêtait une
relation que le conacoh assez
monthey cimo thienpont et les troisièmes
à la cantine et sa facilité à bout de la
course à tarbes il
y en a sept cas ni à
la menthe et
carla mois et
bientôt
des principes et comment il fait valoir
péter diamandis
l'intégrité n'est elle pas les
îles sont mucho pas voilà
l'été clos
président c'est là c'est là bonjour
félicitations d'abord les eaux bien
devenu président ce travail depuis des
années le fruit de ce travail il y aura
pas que le psg qui va bénéficier de tout
ça il y aura aussi le football français
la ligue 1 comment vous voyez les
retombées de tout ce travail de ces
arrivées de ces transferts sur le
football français et la liga
je pense aujourd'hui
pas on n'aime pas on passe de noms mais
je bronze avec tous les skrulls on a
aujourd'hui les joueurs avec des clubs
sincèrement je brosse la championne a
rossé monter les niveaux
tam en fait de deux droits de télé
j'espère aussi documenté que commerces
partenaires aussi moi j'ai maintenant je
pense tout ça c'est c'est vraiment
monter parce que je pense tout le monde
maintenant elle veut voir paris saint
germain avait gardé par le syndicat et
opal saint germain ça ça veut dire
monter de la foule et l'autre club même
quand on joue à l'extérieur
honnêtement j'ai avait remercié tout la
poésie dans l'immeuble et ont envoyé un
message pour remercier
l'arrivée de leo je pense vraiment
j'étais chez je me sentais beaucoup
vraiment beaucoup cette fois à sa porte
pour paris saint germain parce que
j'espère tout le monde le sait qu'est ce
qu'on fait c'est pas bon seulement pour
la classe nous fait pour la france aussi
bon à l'aller les gars ont nagé si je
vous remercie aussi vincent labrune
honnêtement les chaque fois à l'imed
tout la clape spécialement aussi nous
pour supporter la classe
honnêtement j on a on a on a la chance
aujourd'hui on est on est là pour monter
pour travailler comme j'ai dit à tt lors
la travailler vont commencer aujourd'hui
pour tout le monde pour nous ou pour
l'autre club pour la ligue or pour les
villes à à paris parce que je pense
qu'est ce qu'on fait nous pour le bourg
la clape ce pas seulement à bord la
flamme mais aussi pour la ville tout le
monde ne vaut profiter aux
deux dernières questions
philippe sanfourche pour rtl
bonjour président bonjour les eaux
bienvenue à paris
vous l'avez dit qu'en quelques jours
vous imaginiez finir votre carrière à
barcelone où vous avez tout gagné on
imagine que sur le plan sportif le
challenge ne vous effraie pas est ce que
finalement le plus grand défi pour vous
après plus de 20 ans passés à barcelone
c'est un défi de vie de changement de
pays de culture d'une nouvelle langue
pour vous pour votre famille est ce que
c'est ça finalement votre plus gros défi
aujourd'hui
est la racine dans les colonies comme la
guerre
d'irak et fermer la porte à bien que
c'est par rapport à
la salle par un gamin de premier saut
n'a pas réussi un nouvel apéro trotter
préparateur boutisme arana et
un taux la tengo
compagnies amies ou un territoire qui
sonnera facilité à l'épaule elle
pourrait
la coutume le merapi aux dominos
accompagnera et
je préviendrai témoin le sénat - felli
comme une reine allait démissionner tard
avec douleur a dit l'entraîneur économie
à m'accompagner rapporté tyrone
connaissons
il est prêt des fois les
regards braqués
annuel de portiragnes familiale cameron
a une à palencia et rosette à monastir
tout à coup la vie et la mort de tamesna
séquelles notamment dans le train qui
les familles ce
jour alessandri en dse gazzetta dello
sporte une question pour mais c'est il
ya quatre ans il ya quatre ans bella qui
aurait pu venir au barcelo là vous vous
aviez cette envie aussi vous retrouver
ici à paris 80 paires et ce qui peut
être ce qui a été
xavi ou iniesta au barça pour le paris
saint-germain
c'est une douzaine de hockey kevin et
montano caisse ou des six mois et trois
[Musique]
mois
il ya une auto cas ce que je veux dire à
quoi reconnait que l'élection
et son phénoménal au point qu'on ne sait
comme personne apte à miami et son petit
groupe et à google
pour michael essien sur la marque aussi
non et toi tu as le marocain el mundo
l'hôpital et 46 position qui est
grandissime à plat dj one man show pour
à mes joueurs et pourtant l'homme est
par contre à mon
conseiller les locaux s'y attendait ça
ok de paris saint-germain ni aimer
personne la dame
merci merci à tous merci à tous bouts
qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous prie de nous excuser pour jo qui
nous excuser on n'a pas pu prendre
toutes les questions avant de conclure
on va faire une une dernière photo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voici un format
où est ouvert
[Musique]
voilà vous venez de suivre la conférence
de presse de lunettes mais si on est de
retour avec sébastien claira
pour débriefer cette conférence de
presse on va voir les images après un
peu plus tard de lionel messi qui se
déplace en ce moment dans le parc des
princes il va devrait normalement
rejoindre la pelouse de l'as du parc des
princes on a entendu pas mal de choses
pendant cette conférence de presse on
lui a beaucoup posé la question de 6
était plus triste finalement de quitter
le barça ou d'arriver à ap ap ap a paris
il a fait une réponse un peu
moitié-moitié on va dire oui voilà c'est
sûr qu'il est encore un peu bouleversé
de quitter le barça surtout que comme on
l'avait dit tout à l'heure ça c'est fait
extrêmement vite ça s'est fait en
quelques jours il y retrouver deux je
vais prolonger au barça c'est bon je
suis tranquille à me voilà au pg dans un
nouveau club pour la première fois
depuis que j'ai 13 ans donc forcément
c'est un petit peu difficile à digérer
maintenant il a aussi arrivé à paris il
a été reçu par beaucoup de supporters il
a rencontré déjà ses coéquipiers sont
son entraîneur c'est quelque chose qui
peut quand même se dire de ceux dits se
digérer pardon assez vite alors que vous
voyez les images de lionel messi omar da
fonseca qu on a pas mal entendu à la fin
cette conférence vous a entendu
quelqu'un crier mais si mais si mais si
omar da fonseca est ce qu'on peut le
présenter rapidement peut-être oui c'est
notre confrère jean sport consultants
anciens joueurs d'ailleurs notamment au
psg
argentin évidemment grand grand fan de
messi qui a beaucoup commenté ces
matches au barça adorateurs même de
donner si donc forcément on peut se
douter que ça lui fait quelque chose de
le voir en france maintenant est de
pouvoir un petit peu la compagnie andré
on a eu pendant la conférence de presse
nasser el khelaifi qui a commencé en
disant le plus dur commence maintenant
parce que c'est bien beau de d'empiler
les stars on va dire ou d'avoir lionel
messi au bout d'un moment il va falloir
gagner et c'est là que ça va voilà c'est
maintenant qu'il faut se concentrer oui
bien sûr maintenant il ya beaucoup de
travail à faire on en a parlé un petit
peu tout à l'heure sur notamment
l'aspect tactique comment jouer avec
messi qui sera dans le onze de départ
qui ne sera pas surtout il ya encore
beaucoup de travail sur le papier c'est
évidemment très séduisant on a parlé
d'un mercato 5 étoiles maintenant il
faudra traduire ça sur le terrain voilà
vous n'hésitez pas à continuer à poser
vos questions alors qu'on voyait pas le
messie toujours ce qu'il va devrait
bientôt arriver sur la pelouse on a eu
une question tout à l'heure dans
l'interdît dont je n'ai pas regardé le
nom qui pour concurrencer le psg en
ligue 1 est ce que on peut vraiment les
concurrencer cette année en ligue 1 avec
cette équipe chaque année on a
l'impression qu'aucune équipe ne peut
vraiment concurrencer les géants tout
cas qu'il est toujours grand favori
maintenant on a vu que monaco a fait
tomber le psg en 2017 on a vu que lille
vient de faire tomber le paris
saint-germain on voit que ce n'est pas
impossible il ya un an on aurait dit que
lille peut faire tomber ce psg je sais
pas si grand monde à les pronostics et
sao tout cas pas beau monde il y aurait
cru maintenant on peut on peut aussi
remarquer que l'om a réussi a plutôt un
bon mercato est plutôt excitant c'est en
ce début de saison est ce que ça peut
aller jusqu'à concurrencer intel pg ça
paraît quand même parler quand même bien
d'y avoir encore un sacré écart
effectivement alors là vous venez de
voir les images de la du parc des
princes aux abords du parc des princes
où les ultras se sont rassemblé
énormément de personnes à nos
journalistes et sur place et me disais
tout à l'heure qu'effectivement il ya
énormément de personnes qui sont là qui
chantent le msi devrait apparaître pour
ces courses pour ses supporters une
question ça c'était pour la ligue 1 et
la ligue des champions on a entendu hier
des commentaires qui disaient ça y est
c'est gagner le paris saint germain a
l'équipe pour la ligue des champions
mais ça peut être si simple que ça non
bien sûr ça va pas être aussi simple que
ça et d'ailleurs on dit que messi a
gagné quatre fois la ligue des champions
il ya aussi je sais pas peut-être une
dizaine de fois quelque chose comme ça
où il a perdu ou le barça de messi
neymar suarez n'a perdu ou le real de
cristiano ronaldo karim benzema l'a
perdu d'ailleurs ils en font plus
souvent perdu que gagné parce que la
compétition est extrêmement rude ce psg
aujourd'hui a mis toutes les chances de
son côté avec son recrutement maintenant
il faut travailler tout au long de la
saison on a déjà vu le psg être très
séduisant au début de la saison tout cas
sur le papier est ensuite complètement
décevant en ligue des champions
aujourd'hui p j'ai quand même un peu
plus sûr de sa force il une finale une
demie finale il se rapproche pas mal le
psg fait clairement partie des favoris
si ce n'est le favori évidemment paris
va un peu se débarrasser de cette
étiquette de favori pour s'enlever un
petit peu de pression aujourd'hui sur le
papier on peut se dire oui s'il ya un
favori c'est peut-être le paris
saint-germain elle se demande qui est le
concurrent majeur du paris saint-germain
en ligue 1 et en ligue des champions en
lien on pourrait on pourrait plutôt
penché vers vers l'om ou l'ol en tout
cas ça paraît ça paraît le plus logique
sur le papier après peut-être qu'une
équipe va nous surprendre peut-être que
monaco on ne verra peut-être pas venir
mais ils ont fait une grosse seconde
partie de saison niko kovac a cette fois
eu le temps vraiment de travailler avec
son équipe en ligue des champions on
peut penser que chelsea sera encore une
fois tenant du titre bon forcément dans
la course comme manchester city encore
une énorme équipe ils ont été en finale
l'an dernier c'était la première fois
pour eux ils seront forcément dans la
course le barça ça va être beaucoup plus
compliqué aujourd'hui le real madrid est
aussi un petit peu en difficulté n'a pas
vraiment fait un grand mercato donne
quasiment pas recruter on peut aussi
compter sur le bayern munich voilà on
peut considérer que les principaux
concurrents et situant plutôt en
angleterre manchester city chelsea
peut-être liverpool et côté allemagne
avec le bayern je suis en train de voeux
de lire vos commentaires donc vous
n'hésitez pas à continuer à nous poser
des questions on va continuer à y
répondre pendant encore quelque temps
lionel messi est normalement dans les
travées du parc des princes il devrait
bientôt être présents sur le stade on a
eu du nez messi qui nous accueille à
dire quelque chose qui est assez
intéressant c'est qu'il était ravi de
retrouver les coéquipiers faut quand
même savoir qu'il arrive au paris
saint-germain en terrain conquis oui
tout à fait on l'a dit tout à l'heure il
retrouve notamment entre elles dit maria
son compatriote a dit qu'il s'entend
très bien léandro paredes aussi
international argentin avec qui aussi il
a une très bonne relation marco garatti
neymar évidemment qu'ils voulaient
rejouer avec lui depuis longtemps qu'ils
sont très bons amis mauricio pochettino
lui aussi argentin il l'a souligné
messiaen conférence de presse d'ailleurs
que ça à jouer et d'ailleurs pour
l'anecdote mauricio pochettino étaient
sur la pelouse lors du premier match de
lionel messi en professionnel donc ils
ont un peu un lien depuis depuis
toujours c'est sûr que dans le vestiaire
il va bien s'entendre même marquinhos
key dans navas qui sont des adversaires
réguliers notamment copa america ou en
ligue des champions ce sont aussi des
joueurs avec qui lionel messi n'a jamais
caché qu'il s'entendait bien avec il y
avait un grand respect mutuel donc sur
son intégration au vestiaire name is ya
l'air confiant et on peut on a eu la
fameuse question sur neymar forcément
puisque démarre à jouer avec beaulieu
abc lionel messi on disait qu'il
essayait de faire revenir des mares au
paris saint germain au fc barcelone et
finalement c'est messi qui vient et il
vient à paris c'est ça ça avait été le
feuilleton à l'été 2010 9 ou neymar
avait clairement fait savoir qu'il
voulait retourner au marsa qui ne
voulait plus du psg au final paris la
retenue mais marc il voulait surtout
jouer avec messi il a encore dit en
décembre 2020 où il a dit qu'il voulait
rejouer avec missy quand on lui a
demandé où il disait peu importe c'est
pas important moi je veux rejouer avec
messi aujourd'hui l'accueil à paris il
va l'accueillir évidemment un bras
ouverts sur les sur les réseaux sociaux
il a fait des îles envoyé des messages
pour pour montrer qu'il était ravi de sa
qu'il a hâte de rejouer avec lui neymar
c'est un peu l'un des premiers ravis
aujourd'hui de recevoir mais c'est à
paris qu'on imagine et il ya anthony
aussi dans l'est dans les commentaires
qui nous vaut pas une question on a déjà
répondu en première partie mais on va y
répondre à nouveau il devance im ap
partira libre l'année prochaine ou si
une prolongation est toujours
d'actualité aujourd'hui une prolongation
contre 1 n'a plus l'air vraiment
d'actualité en tout cas d'ailleurs
d'après les dernières informations
notamment du journal l'équipe qu'il
disait en tout cas que il est très
improbable que client mbappé quitte le
psg cet été malgré l'arrivée de lionel
messi qu'il reste au psg pour cette
saison une prolongation de contrat n'est
pas non plus vraiment dans les tuyaux
qui aiment bape et a souvent dit moi
j'attends des garanties sportives du psg
avant de prolonger en gros aujourd'hui
il en a et pourtant la prolongation n'a
pas l'air vraiment d'arriver tout cas ça
ne se débouche pas on peut considérer
qu'en fait qu'il aime ap a juste envie
de rejoindre le real madrid un jour ou
l'autre qu'il a décidé que ça sera à
l'été 2022
dont il n'a aucune raison de prolonger
son contrat y partira vraisemblablement
libre à l'été 2009 on a l'impression que
cette bonne entre guillemets des joueurs
qui terminent leur contrat et qui
signent libre c'est quelque chose qui
est de plus en plus présent dans le foot
d'aujourd'hui est ce que c est ce que
c'est juste une impression quoi c'est
peut-être si c'est peut-être une réalité
ça serait intéressant de le compiler un
peu les statistiques pour se rendre
compte si c'est le cas en tout cas avec
le psg on l'a bien remarqué parce que
sergio ramos adjointe yvonne addona
roumain vaginale doom mais si maintenant
sont tous arrivés en fin de contrat
effectivement ça c'est souvent un sujet
on voit notamment mémo barça c'est
encore des joueurs en fin de contrat
damman de leurs grands jeunes qui
s'appelle i like you riba qui est menacé
d'être en tribune pour toute la saison
si jamais ils ne prononcent pas ça c'est
malheureusement une situation qui
arrivent de plus en plus dans le
football où forcément la valeur
économique d'un joueur elle est très
importante donc un joueur qui part en
fin de contrat ça veut dire pas de
telles unités de transfert pas de
rentrées d'argent pour le club forcément
c'est une grosse déception mais par
contre pour joueurs c'est une prime à la
signature et c'est beaucoup plus
important pour lui exactement on as les
boks qui nous demande quand est-ce que
messi commencera à jouer la question a
été posée justement en conférence de
presse et la réponse a été assez flou
oui voilà messieurs esquivé la question
parce que lui même ne le sait peut-être
pas encore vraiment ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il ne jouera pas ce week-end
parce que comme il le disait mais s'il
revient de vacances donc il n'a pas eu
une préparation physique qui n'a pas eu
de pré saison il doit il doit se
préparer à ça d'après les dernières
informations qui circulaient la
préparation physique de mauricio
pochettino au psg n'a absolument rien à
voir avec ce à quoi messi était habitué
à barcelone donc ça va peut-être lui
demander un petit peu de temps pour se
mettre bien physiquement même s'il est
plutôt en forme on peut on peut
peut-être imaginer au mieux que messi
joue dans dix jours pour pour son
premier match mais il est aussi possible
qu'il ne joue pas pour pour le mois
d'août ce qui aurait une trêve
internationale ensuite début septembre
qu'il joue donc avec l'argentine peut
être qu'ils jouent ces prêts les matchs
de la saison et qu'il revienne vers le
12 13 septembre pour jouer au psg
d'accord donc on n'est pas sur un débat
sur sur un début de saison qui pour
arriver à leur être patient il faudrait
pas sûr en tout cas c'est fortement
improbable qu'il commence à jouer ce
week end comme il l'a lui-même comme
comme il ya quand même lui même répondu
on avait une question qui était assez
intéressante il faut que je la retrouve
[Musique]
c'est tout un mode qui se demandent s'il
arrivait de messi pourrait pousser et
mbappé à partir finalement est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est un argument
positif mais est ce que finalement ça
n'a pas aussi le faire partir
moi j'ai tendance à penser que c'est
plutôt un argument positif l'idée de
jouer avec lionel messi
pour lui c'est maintenant que jamais
c'est cette saison il y en aura pas
d'autre je pense que tous les grands
joueurs veulent jouer avec les grands
joueurs que lui ça ça les excite
forcément un peu du dojo avec neymar et
messi déjà avec neymar il s'entendait
très bien je pense que neymar il est
absolument il est aux anges à l'idée de
jouer avec deux amis à lui qu'ils sont
aussi forts je pense même qu'il ait
acquis la du dirham ap le plus grand
bien de messier à lutter tu vas voir
mais c'est génial on va jouer ensemble
on va se régaler je pense que bafé a
quand même envie de jouer cette saison
au psg il sait qu'il a une vraie chance
de gagner la ligue des champions qui a
une vraie chance de se mettre en avant
et de performer il voulait des garanties
sur le projet sportif pour prolonger
alors peut-être qu'il ne prolongera pas
mais en tout cas l'aïd c'est qu'il y ait
un vrai projet sportif au moins pour
cette saison il sait qu'il est dans une
grande équipe je pense que il peut il
peut vraiment avoir envie de jouer cette
saison même si jamais il s'en va
derrière on a une question qui revenait
tout à l'heure sur le sur la ligue des
champions
l'an dernier c'est chelsea qui a gagné
qui n'étaient pas favoris finalement
est-ce que cette compétition peut
essayer de gagner par un outsider et pas
par une des normes écuries oui bien sûr
on peut toujours avoir toujours avoir
des surprises les années précédentes
c'était un petit peu moins le coeur on a
vu le real madrid qui avait gagné trois
saisons de suite qu'ils avaient vraiment
une domination totale on a eu le bayern
munich en 2020 qui avait un effectif un
effectif extrêmement riche et qui
écrasait tout sur son passage qui a
gagné quasiment tous ses matches sur les
30 derniers matches de la saison
on a quand même rarement des autres
cider qui viennent un petit peu de nulle
part même liverpool en 2019 il avait
perdu en 2018 il gagne ensuite en 2019
donc il était quand même assez ont rompu
à ce niveau de la compétition il a été
bien préparé
on peut toujours avoir des surprises
aujourd'hui en tout cas le psg est
largement favoris par rapport à d'autres
clubs ne serait ce qu'avec le real ou le
barca c'est par exemple et j'ai trébuché
face à l'issue de face à une de ses
équipes ça serait une énorme déception
aujourd'hui peut toujours avoir une
surprise mais là quand même on a
quelques mastodontes qui sont bien armé
quoi est ce que dans la hesse que
maintenant le paris saint germain
rejoint le bayern et manchester city
comme les trois gros clubs grand favori
oui alors est ce que ce sont les trois
certains vous dira peut-être quand même
on peut former un big fort avec chelsea
où il faut faire attention à manchester
united à liverpool certains clubs qu'il
faut un petit peu un petit peu
surveillés on peut même avoir peut-être
une surprise avec avec la juventus
pourquoi pas même si c'est un peu un
bateau qui tanguait pas mal ces derniers
mois
maintenant le psg aujourd'hui est
vraiment installés dans ce gotha des
très très gros club son recrutement
s'inscrit clairement son recrutement de
cet été en tout cas s'inscrit clairement
dans cette lignée on a une question dont
répondu avant avant la conférence de
presse mais me voir comment ces détails
59 kg s'interroge sur la sur la rumeur
selon laquelle cristiano ronaldo
pourrait maintenant lui arrivé au paris
saint germain est-ce que c'est probable
comme aujourd'hui ça paraît totalement
improbable ça paraissait probable
lorsque notamment de l'avenir de m hab
était en question où il y avait
peut-être une possibilité de jeu de
dominos avec maps et qui s'en va qui du
coup libère l'espace pour un ronaldo pg
la juventus qui pourrait enfin se
décharger du salaire de ronaldo l'a
aujourd'hui ça paraît juste impensable
que ronaldo signe au psg en tout cas cet
été dans un an deux ans on a envie de
dire que non mais en même temps il ya un
mois on aurait dit que messi allait
signer au psg pour jouer avec neymar est
d'à p pas grand monde l'aurait cru il ya
vraiment ce côté tout est possible
aujourd'hui en tout cas pour l'instant
on n'est pas prêt de voir ronaldo pg on
a les images du paris saint germain qui
montre que le msi va arriver dans sur la
pelouse du parc des princes où il est
attendu on a vu nos remarques est assez
intéressante c'est neymar quand il
quitte barcelone pour venir à paris il
dit en somme je veux être je veux mais
je veux mon équipe je il était dans le
monde 2 de lionel messi est finalement
maintenant mais s'il revient il est très
heureux est ce que c'est un peu un aveu
d'échec pour lui oui ça peut paraître
assez surprenant c'était peut-être même
déjà un aveu d'échec pour neymar en 2019
lorsqu'il voulait retourner au barça
comme si finalement il ne se sentait pas
de jouer ce rôle-là au psg au final il a
quand même réussi un peu à l'embrasser
avec avec bape et neymar reste quand
même sur une grosse saison alors certes
il a encore manqué quelques matches mais
on a très bien vu qu'il y avait un psg
avec et sans neymar
ça peut paraître un petit peu un petit
peu surprenant peut-être que neymar
s'est rendu compte aussi que il a besoin
de jouer avec ces grands joueurs pour
pour réussir et qu'il s'agit pas juste
d'être la star avec des joueurs lambda
autour pour réussir on a johnny
justement qui nous demandaient qui qui
posait cette question de neymar qui
avait quitté le fc barcelone j'espère
que cette cette réponse dire à douala
vous voyez de dan messi qui est sur la
pelouse du stade du parc des princes qui
semble partir on a une question assez
intéressante aussi sur la suite du
mercato du paris saint germain est
plutôt dans le sens des départs quid de
liccardi draxler sarabia il va falloir
vendre pour le paris saint-germain quand
même oui bien sûr il va falloir vendre
parce que comme le disait le journal
l'équipe ce matin le psg l'a promis à la
dncg donc le gendarme financier du
football français qu'il allait vendre
pour 180 millions d'euros cette année
aujourd'hui il en est très loin je crois
qu'il n'y a que mitchell baker qui a été
vendu pour un montant estimé à 7
millions d'euros que sur 180 millions
d'euros ça fait pas beaucoup ma roue et
chardy son départ est assez probable
mais encore faut-il trouver quelqu'un
quelqu'un pour l'acheter on rappelle p g
l avait acheté pour 50 millions d'euros
l'an dernier ça va être compliqué de le
guérir et sociaux voilà c'est sur ce
montant ça va être un petit peu
difficile il ya julian reister qui a
souvent été annoncé sur le départ thilo
querrey rossi qui a été annoncé
potentiellement partants qui en plus est
assez jeune qui a un vrai potentiel mine
de rien même s'il est très compliqué
pour lui à paris effectivement pablo
sarabia le psg va être obligé de
dégraisser son effectif et c'est vrai
que pour le coup icardi sarabia qui joue
dans le secteur offensif avec l'arrivée
de messier forcément le temps de jeu va
encore se réduire donc les départs sont
d'autant plus probable effectivement
alors vous venez de voir lionel messi
qui a posé avec le maillot
du paris saint germain qui est
maintenant qui rentre maintenant dans le
parc des princes ce jeu il devrait
bientôt arrêter leur leurs flux vidéo on
imagine en une question assez
intéressante aussi de l'initiale gold
qui me dit est ce que le vestiaire ne
risque pas d'exploser avec autant de
stars on se rappelle des galactiques du
real madrid au début des années 2000
ronaldo le brésilien le vrai comme on
appelle comme on l'appelle david beckham
luis figo zinédine zidane est ce que
empilés star c'est un gage de succès un
gage de succès non ça c'est certain que
non maintenant ce qui est très
intéressant et que avec le pg on en
avait déjà parlé avant la conférence de
presse c'est d'essayer de voir qui sont
ces stars et comment peuvent-ils
cohabiter ensemble parce qu'une star
n'est pas juste une star il ya
différentes stars il ya différentes
personnalités de différents leaders
différents capitaine lionel messi n'est
pas le même n'a pas la même personnalité
qu'un sergio ramos vannes l2 n'a
peut-être pas la même personnalité qu'un
qu'un marquinhos aucun quilliam bape et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que messi
n'est pas un joueur qui tire forcément
leur couverture à lui-même qui cherche
absolument à être la grande vedette
alors que c'est peut-être un peu plus le
cacher un art ou un qui a emballé par
exemple que par exemple à marquinhos
sergio ramos sont vraiment des leaders
vocaux qui parle beaucoup qui n'ont pas
peur des micros à assumer la
responsabilité devant tout le monde ray
et à violer un petit peu si pour
permettre à violer un petit peu sur sur
les autres si nécessaire ce qui est un
peu moins le caractère d'un messi qui
s'exprime plus sur la pelouse donc on
peut considérer que ce sont des joueurs
qui ont quand même envie de jouer
ensemble qu'ils ont envie de réussir
ensemble
si le vestiaire explose ça me parait ça
me paraîtrait assez surprenant en tout
cas au vu des personnalités de cette
équipe on a les images là
deviennent messi qui est rentré sur la
pelouse du parc des princes qui est
maintenant dans les coursives et qui
devrait à mon avis dans pas longtemps
arrivé à la tribune du parc des princes
on a vu qu'ils avaient énormément de
personnes sur place beaucoup d'ultra
sons notre sont sa venue était suivi
depuis trois jours par une amende
personnes en avant tony qui nous poser
une petite question sur le recrutement
de paris une mauvaise qu'il est terminé
il ne parlait d'une rumeur de hernandez
alors j'ai pas si c'est le cas ou ter
d'ânesse est ce que est ce qu'on peut
penser que le recrutement du paris saint
germain est terminée font peu plus tôt
le penser parce que parce qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui déjà il y aura l'aspect
financier sur sur la place qu'ils ont
encore sur le budget ils ont encore
alloué en termes de masse salariale il y
avait encore des rumeurs la semaine
dernière notamment ne serait ce que sur
sur paul pogba par exemple clairement
aujourd'hui c'est pas un recrutement
faisable je pense financièrement
maintenant que xi est arrivé alors que
on va couper un peu parce que voilà il
ya les images de lionel messi qui est
sur place peut-être qu'on peut avoir un
peu de l'image de son parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
c'est là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
non
voilà vous venez de vous décevoir je
sais pas si on entend bien mais vous
venez de voir lionel messi qui était
avec les supporters parisiens qui lui
ont fait qu'ils ont fait un triomphe ils
attendaient ça on se rappelle de votre
appel de l'arrivée de neymar aussi
qu'avait été qui a été une grande fête
là on a vu on a vu du fumigène on a vu
beaucoup de monde sur place quand je
vois ces images je me dis qu'est-ce
qu'on se rend compte de ce qu'il faudra
se passer de messi qui signe au psg oui
c'est assez fou de le voir déambuler
comme ça et de taper un peu là dans la
main des supporters je sais pas ce qu'il
se rende compte que ils ont lionel messi
devant eux ils ont l'un des tout
meilleurs joueurs si ce n'est le
meilleur joueur de l'histoire c'est
c'est des images c'est incroyable de
voir lionel messi dans un environnement
qui n'est pas celui du fc barcelone de
le voir en costard comme ça ça lui des
supporters devant le parc des princes
ces images assez folle c'est assez
incroyable on avait une question sur les
sur la ligue 1 est ce que finalement
cette arrivée de toutes ces stars est-ce
que ça quitté quel est l'impact pourra
libérer ce que ça
j'avais un commentaire qui disait
justement que ils vont détruire la ligue
1 il n'y aura plus de compétition est ce
que toi tu pense la même chose ou est ce
que justement ça peut te tirer tous vers
le haut sur sur l'équité sportive sa
sueur sur l'impact de la ligue en tout
cas c'est un énorme débat c'est une très
très bonne question sur l'équité
sportive
j'aurais envie de dire est ce qu'il y
avait vraiment de la concurrence avant
et est ce que c'est le transfert de
lionel messi qui va faire que a
maintenant il n'ya il n'y a plus il n'y
a plus aucune chance d'atteindre le psg
le barça a perdu des titres de champion
d'espagne alors que lionel messi était
là quand même beaucoup plus perdu que de
le gagner je pense aussi
j'veux pas sûr que ce soit l'arrivée de
miel messi qui fasse tout bascule à ce
niveau là maintenant sur l'impact que
cela peut avoir sur la ligue 1
évidemment c'est une image inc c'est une
très bonne nouvelle pour tous les
joueurs pour trouver les supporters de
se dire je vais croiser lionel messi
maintenant en ligue 1 maintenant sur
l'impact économique ça c'est une
question qui revient beaucoup aussi est
ce que la ligue 1 va t'en bénéficier que
ça on a vu que les arrivées de zlatan
ibrahimovic de neymar de maps et n'ont
pas fait que les clubs de liens les
autres clubs de ligue 1 les clubs moyens
de bas de tableau se sont mis à rouler
sur l'or qui n'ont pas tant bénéficié
que ça donc sur la pâte sur la ligne 1
je pense qu'au final il sera quand même
assez assez modérée vous n'hésitez pas à
continuer à poser vos questions on va
essayer d'y répondre
on va peut-être des jeunes de petite
question est ce que messi va t-il faire
ses adieux au fc barcelone au camp nou
est ce que ça c'est plus possible au
final ça aujourd'hui c'est compliqué ça
n'a pas pu se faire et on a vu que ça là
que ça n'a blessé beaucoup il me parlait
tout à l'heure en conférence de presse
il ya aussi ce sujet qu'il peut
peut-être affronter le barça en ligue
des champions c'est une possibilité
qu'il aille au camp nou et dire à ce
moment là au revoir à ses supporters
enfin au revoir il sera déjà il sera de
la partie depuis longtemps à ce moment
là mais qu'il leur fasse un au moins un
petit tour de stade un peu un petit un
petit message d'adieu de les voir en
vrai forcément on l'a vu la conférence
de presse domicile lorsqu'il a quitté le
barça c'était quand même assez triste il
était juste dans une conférence de
presse en costard avec ses amis des
journalistes et ancien coéquipier
évidemment il aimerait pouvoir sûrement
revenir au camp nou et pouvoir revoir au
moins une dernière fois les supporters
ont une question de heinz qui nous
demande qui nous demandent comment le
psg et est arrivé à ne pas être touchés
financièrement comme d'autres clubs on
en a parlé c'est le faire à fameux fair
play financier qui a été allégé c'est ça
oui le fair play financier tout la crise
sanitaire et donc économique a été assez
alléger d'ailleurs on a vu que d'autres
gros clubs ont profité notamment
manchester city qui a dépensé plus de
cent millions d'euros pour acheter jack
greliche qui qui serait presque capable
peut-être de faire de maître la même
somme sur harry caine de tottenham donc
on voit aujourd'hui que certains clubs
souffrent un petit peu moins de la crise
surtout surtout parce qu'ils ont ils ont
vraiment des moyens colossaux derrière
qui n'ont pas autant de dettes et qui
n'ont pas autant de difficultés à
éponger leurs dettes comme par exemple
le fc barcelone s'était notamment l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles le contrat
de messi n'a pas pu au final être
prolongé il ya des clubs qui en
souffrent effectivement - et le pg s'est
notamment une de ses forces c'est qui
peut un peu dépensé 100 millions d'euros
sur un mercato se rater complètement et
faire comme si de rien n'était ce que
tous les clubs ne peuvent pas se
permettre effectivement on est une
question assez rapide et qui demandait
quand été le premier match de leo messi
avec le psg on n'en sait encore rien
mais a priori ça pourrait peut-être
après la trêve internationale début
septembre ou fin août on ne sait pas
encore en tout cas très peu probable de
le voir ce week-end sur les pelouses de
de ligue 1 voilà il va falloir être
patient quoi qu'il arrive on ne verra
pas lionel messi avec le maillot du psg
ce week-end sauf énorme surprise il l'a
dit lui-même en conférence de presse
d'ailleurs il revient juste de vacances
il n'a pas eu de pré saison de
préparation physique il n'a besoin de ça
il a besoin d'être d'arrivée vraiment
formes peinture et ensuite toute la
saison
peut-être qu'on le verra jouer que le
psg la semaine prochaine après le match
de ce week end il ya encore deux matches
avant la trêve internationale de début
septembre
il est possible qu'il ne rejoue que 12
13 septembre en tout cas la mi-septembre
avec le psg une fois qu'il sera vraiment
prêt physiquement on a une question
aussi est-ce que neymar et messi se sont
croisés depuis l'arrivée de l'argentin à
paris ou pas encore on ne sait pas
vraiment pas pour la vue avec certains
de ses coéquipiers voilà on l'a vu à
certains de ses coéquipiers on la dépose
chez tino avec hakim -notamment je crois
ce qu'il avait déjà croisé neymar ça on
ne sait pas ce qu'on pense qu'on peut ce
qu'on peut imaginer c'est qu'il ya du
avoir pas mal de textos qui ont été qui
ont été échangés en tout cas neymar a
beaucoup réagit sur les sur les réseaux
sociaux pour montrer qu'il était ravi
que messi le rejoigne à paris
on a maintenant hâte de les voir surtout
sur le terrain une question auxquelles
on a déjà un peu répandu c'est ce que
l'arrivée de messi va-t-elle pousser di
maria vers la porte du club ou juste sur
le banc
vers la porte du club ce serait quand
même une énorme surprise surtout que ce
sont deux hommes qui s'entendent très
bien qu'ils se retrouvent souvent
sélection qui ont une très bonne
relation au départ de di maria n'a
jamais été envisagé du côté du psg je
crois qu'il lui reste un an de contrat
peut-être deux au maximum
un départ n'est franchement pas envisagé
du côté du psg surtout qu'ils restent
encore sur une très belle saison qu'il a
encore beaucoup de choses à apporter à
paris par contre l'idée qu'il se
retrouve sur le banc ça c'est une vraie
possibilité
mais cinéma mbappé ces trois là d'un jeu
quoi qu'il arrive est ce que le psg peut
jouer avec en trail di maria en plus
donc avec un 4e attaquant on va dire
mais c'est pas un avant-centre non plus
et c'est plus un ailier voire à la
limite un milieu de terrain il a parfois
joué au milieu de terrain même avec à
l'époque du real madrid avant le psg
aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus compliqué
pour lui surtout à son âge à 33 ans je
crois
effectivement en trail di maria il ya
une possibilité pour caen en ligue des
champions ils fassent un peu les frais
de ce recrutement cinq étoiles on a une
question aussi sur excuse mais si
finalement va pas finir sa carrière au
psg maintenant qu'il arrivait à cet âge
là est-ce qu'on peut on peut s'attendre
à une fin de carrière au psg bien sûr
c'est une possibilité aujourd'hui il a
une à 34 ans mais s'il sera sur sous
contrat pour deux ans donc jusqu'à 36
ans avec une troisième année en option
est-ce qu'il va finir sa carrière au psg
en europe donc c'est tout à fait
possible il ya aussi la possibilité
qu'il aille jouer en mls aux états unis
ça a été une des grandes rumeur qui n'a
pas été plus développé que ça parce que
nous les messines on n'est pas du tout
encore là encore il a encore beaucoup à
revendre pour le football est encore
envie de jouer au top niveau européen
ça aussi une possibilité qu'ils aillent
finir sa carrière un peu à la manière
d'un david beckham typiquement
aux etats-unis ou dans un pays un petit
peu plus lointain que l'europe eh bien
on va encore prendre quelques questions
vous n'hésitez pas à continuer à en
poser on alexis jouanno qui monde mais
messi a signé dans quel club on peut
dire qu'elle paris saint-germain leur
argent leurs variantes raillard
d'ailleurs il est en interview en ce
moment sur au parc des princes comme
vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
proposées pas l'ordinateur de ce live
ryad vous pouvez le voir répondre aux
questions des du paris saint germain il
a quand même répondu déjà pas mal de
questions donc on va on ne vous mettra
pas des sons en une question qui revient
une nouvelle fois c'est ce que m bape et
va terminer cette saison au psg où il va
partir au real de madrid dès cette année
où finalement attendre juste l'an
prochain a priori il va attendre
attendre l'an prochain en tout cas c'est
le journal l'équipe qui disait qu'un
départ de guillaume labbé était très
improbable aujourd'hui en fin de contrat
dans un an même s'il ne prolonge pas au
final la décision lui appartient le psg
a beau essayer de le prolonger s'ils n'y
arrivent pas ils n'y arrivent pas ils
vont pas a priori forcément se forcer en
tout cas à le vendre maintenant
il est assez probable que kim ap keep
you club ensuite l'année prochaine c'est
clairement le scénario vers lequel on se
dirige aujourd'hui pour parler un peu de
la façon dont on va jouer le paris saint
germain on est une question qui
demandait est ce que le paris saint
germain va devoir tout articulé autour
de lionel messi comment finalement va
jouer le paris saint germain
tout articulé c'est une très bonne
question est ce que est ce que l'équipe
va va totalement changer par rapport à
lionel messi
c'est une question c'est possible parce
que le barça
était forcément a toujours été dépendant
de messi a toujours dû construire son
équipe autour de lui n'a jamais même eu
à vraiment à se poser la question
surtout messi à 34 ans c'est pas un
joueur qui va faire un million d'efforts
pour courir partout pour pour faire pour
assurer un grand repli défensif donc
forcément il faut il faut un petit peu
s'adapter et trouver la bonne formule
pour que le psg joue vraiment une équipe
comme on le disait tout à l'heure avant
la conférence de presse pour qu'il n'y
ait pas sept joueurs d'un côté et les
trois attaquants devant et un no man's
land au milieu donc le psg devra
forcément paul chez tino d'avoir
forcément s'adapter anisi aux joueurs de
son équipe et chercher le bon moyen de
le faire coexister avec le reste de
l'équipe on a sion qui nous demandent
comment il faut vous retrouverez
question mais s'il va retrouver quatre
joueurs du real quelle sera son attitude
dans le vestiaire vis-à-vis de ses
anciens ennemis tu disais qu'à priori ça
devrait plutôt bien se passer oui à
priori ça devrait bien se passer ça va
être assez ça serait assez marrant de
pouvoir de voir la rencontre entre
messier ramos parce qu'elles ont
toujours été sur tes rivaux pendant 10
ou 15 ans n'ont pas toujours été je
pense que les plus grands amis du monde
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'animosité
sur le sur le terrain entre le real et
le barça maintenant ce sont deux joueurs
aussi qui ça fonctionne et je pense en
bonne intelligence ramos il a une énorme
expérience comme messi ils savent qu'ils
sont là pour gagner ensemble et avec le
reste des joueurs je pense qu'il n'y
aura aucun problème avec quelle en aval
ce qui est un des anciens madrilènes
messi a toujours eu une relation très
courtoise et ils sont déjà croisés même
en copa america ils ont pu se croiser à
dons à d'autres occasions les autres
joueurs madrilènes les anciens
madrilènes c'est di maria il ya un des
meilleurs années messier dans ce
vestiaire donc je pense pas que messi
aura de gros problèmes en terme
d'intégration alors on avait la question
de clément et vincent qui nous repose
toujours la question sur quand est ce
que sera le pré mal de mais si on vient
d'y répondre
est-ce que qui va jouer dans les cages
augmente encore une fois de naro mauna
vase comment on va pouvoir se répartit
entre ces deux grands gardiens
ça c'est ça c'est une grande question
c'est en a parlé tout à l'heure sur la
concurrence entre deux gardiens de top
niveau est ce que ça peut marcher il n'y
a pas beaucoup d'exemples par le passé
qui nous prouve que c'est une bonne
formule qu'elle en alsace il n'avait pas
caché qu'il était assez surpris voire
même mécontent que qu'à un gardien de ce
niveau là soient recrutés alors que
lui-même restait sur une excellente
saison en tant que j'en ai une vidéo
dans la roma il est jeune c'est l'avenir
il a été élu meilleur joueur de l'euro
2000 20 pas meilleur gardien meilleurs
joueurs c'est dire son impact avec
l'italie où il a gagné l'euro donc
aujourd'hui puccino va devoir trancher
est ce qui leur fait partager la
compétition par exemple un joueur qui a
un gardien qui joue la ligue 1 un
gardien qui joue la ligue des champions
ça c'est une possibilité pour essayer de
contenter un petit peu tout le monde
sait peut-être même la meilleure de
trancher maintenant est de dire on fera
comme ci comme ça et ne pas en mettre un
titulaire tout le temps et de dire si
jamais tu es pas bon peut-être que je
mets l'eau autre sinon la fectivement ça
peut ça peut créer une relation tendue
et ça peut être un peu quelque chose qui
va plus handicapé le paris saint-germain
qu'autre chose alors que dans la roma
c'est censé être une excellente recrue
on a tous fait qu'ils mentent quand la
conférence de presse débute elle a
démarré à 11 heures je t'invite à
regarder le live ea et à le reprendre
elle a commencé à peu près à 11h05 on a
vu une question il faudrait qu'il
faudrait que la retrouve alors sur amos
on vous a répondu aussi en défense
centrale la question de la défense
centrale est assez importante puisque on
avait marqué niasse kimbembe une
charnière qui marchait bien qui monte en
puissance là on va rajouter ramos qui
est ce que quelqu'un va perdre sa place
ou pas
la question à trois c'est ça aussi c'est
la possibilité de jouer à trois derrière
donc avec trois défenseurs centraux de
marquinhos kimbembe ramos sinon il va
falloir faire des concessions ce qu'on
sait en tout cas c'est que pour
l'instant ramos n'est pas prêt
physiquement il s'était il s'était
blessé récemment pour l'instant ce n'est
pas encore un sujet tout de suite
d'autant que marquinhos marc qui nous
revient de la copa america kimbembe mois
eu l'euro mais le seul à terminer un
petit peu plus tôt donc ils sont un peu
plus ils vont ils vont monter en
puissance physiquement d abandonner
politi no va devoir faire des choix en
ligue des champions si jamais il joue à
trois derrière les effectivement il fera
le choix de ne pas choisir
sinon il y en a forcément sur le banc ce
sera aussi quelque chose à digérer on
peut partir du principe que marquinhos
ne serait jamais puisque c'est le
capitaine du paris saint-germain que
ramos en même temps si on la fait
devenir pour le mettre sur le banc c'est
assez assez étrange surtout que c'est
encore un joueur d'un top niveau
maintenant on peut aussi penser que
ramos avec son expérience son vécu c'est
peut-être un joueur qui peut accepter de
parfois être sur le banc de laisser les
autres s'exprimer pour le bien de
l'équipe qui va peut-être pas essayer de
tirer la couverture à lui même on à
matisse qui lui demandait ce qu'il ya un
risque que les joueurs n'arrivent pas à
s'adapter au style de jeu de messi
j'en doute un petit peu parce que je
pense que quand tout cas que neymar va
tout faire pour parce que on l'a dit
voulait absolument rejouer avec missy
donc là dessus ça paraît peu probable
qu'ils ne s'adapte pas à lui la question
peut se poser un petit peu sûr qu'il ya
la paix qui est un joueur qui est qui et
mec qui aime beaucoup parfois décrocher
touché beaucoup de ballons alors qu'il
peut être très bon dans la profondeur
avec même parfois on a vu ses
coéquipiers en plein match lui dire mais
va dans la profondeur ne t'inquiète pas
court on va te donner les ballons arrête
de venir les prendre à chaque fois au
départ on peut se poser la question
maintenant c'est aussi une chance inouïe
de jouer avec messi et s'entendre avec
lui il ya d'autres joueurs je pense
qu'ils sont absolument ravis à l'idée de
jouer avec lui marco garatti en trendy
maria même un marc innocent presnell qui
paie mais je pense qu'ils sont très
contents de se dire qu'ils vont avoir
messi devant eux mais qu'ils vont
pouvoir jouer avec lui
on verra sur les premiers matchs sur les
premiers rendez vous
c'est vrai qu'il ya ce côté il ya qu un
seul ballon maintenant je pense que
messi va tout faire pour que ça marche
et notamment neymar et c'est déjà pas
mal on a eu l'occasion justement de
kilrea qui demandent qui va être buteur
j'aime que c'est le poste d'avant-centre
qui va être vrai poste d'avant centre
entre neymar mba pmsi où est-ce qu'ils
vont jouer tous les trois comme des
électrons libres ça c'est aussi une des
idées des grands maux de tête que va
peut-être avoir mauricio pochettino dans
l'est dans les prochains mois comment
comment faire jouer ces trois là est ce
que il va un peu leur dire vous jouez
vous jouez tous les trois devant je vous
donne de trois consignes histoire 2 mais
après vous êtes des joueurs avec de
l'expérience du vécu vous animez la taca
3 c'est aussi une possibilité c'est des
joueurs qui sont capables de se
débrouiller peut-être naître un petit
peu autosuffisant
on peut penser que c'est plutôt qu'il
bat p qui tiendrait ce rôle d'avant
centre s'il y en a un qui devait le
tenir maintenant neymar et mi6 ont un
instinct de buteur aussi extrêmement
développé c'est des joueurs qui vont
bouger tout le temps bah pays peut très
bien s'excentrer pour laisser de
l'espace à un joueur qui va prendre la
kz
je pense qu'il faut pas trop se fier au
schéma de départ en tout cas on veut
dire puisqu'ils vont jouer en 4 3 3 en 4
4 2 ça va tellement bougé que ça ne sera
pas le plus important on est d'accord le
alors on va comprendre les questions
vous êtes très très nombreux vous encore
vous êtes encore plus de plus de 1000 à
nous suivre en ce moment oui exemple à
ce que la conférence de presse est passé
on a une question sur achraf à kimi est
ce que c'est le meilleur latéral du
monde actuellement
le meilleur latéral du monde ça c'est
une question assez assez vaste est ce
que est ce que c'est sur la saison
dernière est ce que c'est dans l'absolu
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est un des meilleurs
latéraux droits du monde aujourd'hui
c'est une excellente recrue pour le
paris saint germain à 60 millions
d'euros évidemment ça a un certain prix
mais c'est un joueur qui a que 22 23 ans
qui est vraiment en train de monter en
puissance qui a déjà réussi ses débuts
contre 3 il n'a marqué un magnifique but
pour cent pour son premier match en
ligue 1
c'est une excellente recrue à ce niveau
là on a souvent critiqué les le poste
des latéraux paris saint germain on a
souvent dit que c'est là où il y avait
des petites feuilles aujourd'hui le pg
complètement a fait vraiment ce qu'il
fallait pour le poste de latéral droit
ils ont pris un des tous meilleurs du
monde on passe comme de florencia acquis
mais effectivement ça va être une
belle différence on à stéphane qui nous
demandent que pensez-vous de la
relations futures entre messi et
pochettino on ya déjà un peu répondu oui
ben mais si il ya même un petit peu
répondu en conférence de presse il n'a
pas caché que coach et qui doit jouer un
certain rôle devant dans sa venue que
c'est son compatriote il insiste un
petit peu là dessus mais si
il n'y a pas vraiment de doute à avoir
je pense sur l'entente entre pau cetin
rythme ici surtout paul keating qui
généralement s'entend très bien avec ses
joueurs est très proche d'eux ça devrait
très bien se passer on l'avait dit pour
l'anecdote poggetti nom était sur le
terrain lors du tout premier match de la
carrière professionnelle de lionel messi
il ya toujours eu un petit lien entre
les deux
franchement je pense que sûrs et le
messie va très bien s'entendre avec paul
chez tino la question c'est plus est ce
que l'alchimie va se créer ensuite avec
tout le reste de l'équipe est bien merci
beaucoup merci à vous d'avoir d'avoir
suivi ce live nous d'avoir posé des
questions à peut-être finir par une
petite question
messi qui arrivent en france qui arrive
au psg est ce que maintenant c'est parti
le père ap le paris saint germain va
gagner la ligue des champions
en tout cas là maintenant il n'a
peut-être jamais été autant autant
favori enfin je sais pas si c'est le
favori numéro 1 mais il n'a jamais été
aussi proche de pouvoir dire je suis le
favori au départ de la saison maintenant
encore une fois c'est sur le papier ça
mais ici aussi beaucoup insisté là
dessus en conférence de presse naceri
qualifier aussi à on a beaucoup parlé
pour l'instant le psg n'a rien gagné n'a
pas encore gagné de match de ligue des
champions cette saison donc il faut
essayer de rester mesuré et de voir
comment cette équipe va fonctionner on
sait jamais ce qui peut se passer dans
une saison des blessures différents
différents différents évènements qui
peuvent survenir et en tous cas le psg
n'a jamais semblé aussi bien armé pour
gagner des champions ça peut me dire ou
alors vous êtes vraiment très nombreux à
continuer à poser des questions au
moment où je dis que c'est la dernière
du coup on voit peut-être en prend
encore quelques-unes est-ce que messi
peut gagner un ballon d'or au psg et
parce que derrière les favoris pour os
qui les favoris cette année déjà il ya
cette question du ballon dans cette
année ce sera peut-être la première fois
qu'un joueur du paris saint-germain
recevra le ballon d'or au parc des
princes
j'aurais tendance à penser qu'il est
favori cette année donc déjà il peut en
gagner 1 au psg en n'ayant joué que 3 4
mois et ce qui peut en gagner deux oui
c'est tout à fait possible
maintenant est ce que il peut autant
surnager et se mettre en valeur dans ce
psg là avec neymar avec ba paix avec
toutes les stars ça c'est aussi une
question peut-être que c'est un neymar
ou un bape et qui va en profiter keira
autre remake voler la vedette et il se
mettre un peu plus en avant on sait
aussi qu'en 2022 il aura la coupe du
monde en fin d'année c'est peut-être ce
qui va tout changer donc ce sera très
difficile de se projeter à l'avance mais
s'il a aujourd'hui la rejoindre et léger
qui est bien parti pour gagner plusieurs
titres peut-être la ligue des champions
à partir de là il met déjà pas mal de
chances de son côté mais on a des roms
qui demandait ce que le risque du psg
n'est pas sa faible profondeur de banc
quelque chose qu'ils ont quand même
précis a plutôt bien géré et maintenance
et s'est avancé que c'était une
faiblesse avant maintenant on peut dire
que par rapport aux autres équipes ils
n'ont plus grand chose à leur envier oui
je pense que déjà on en parlait tout à
l'heure par rapport à di maria qui
pourrait être le grand perdant
de l'arrivée de messi ce qui ne serait
plus titulaire à voir entre elles di
maria sur le banc ce quand même plutôt
pas mal ça donne une assez bonne valeur
au banc on a parlé de marquinhos
kimbembe ramos peut être un qui serait
sur le banc si sergio ramos est sur le
banc ça aussi c'est pas mal aujourd'hui
ils ont peut-être
2d mais je sais pas des dix meilleurs
gardiens au monde des cinq meilleurs
gardiens au monde en tout cas je pense
pas qu'ils aient un club en europe qui
est deux gardiens d'un tel niveau
il ya encore des postes peut-être à se
perfectionner sur les postes des
latéraux notamment latéral gauche tout à
l'heure on avait une question sur sûreté
ou hernandez c'est peut-être un joueur
qui peut encore renforcer le psg à voir
quel prix bien sûr mais au milieu de
terrain je pense que le psg a quand même
grosse profondeur d'effectif aujourd'hui
si jamais il faut faire jouer di maria
ça veut dire qu'il n'ya que deux milieux
de terrain qui peuvent être titulaires
donc il y en a pas mal qui vont être sur
le banc et qui ont quand même un bon
niveau donc aujourd'hui le psg a quand
même un effectif oui très riche on à la
scène en parlant de ans pendant ce
mercato d'être fiers car ça est-ce que
le psg a d'autres projets de recrue ou
de transfert d'eau tourné en courant la
semaine dernière il y avait encore un
petit peu des rumeurs évidemment ce sont
toutes éteintes depuis que depuis qu'il
ya le sujet mais si parce qu'on ne parle
plus que d'eux mais si mais si mais si
maintenant il y avait encore des rumeurs
sur le paul pogba qui semble aujourd'hui
impossible à envisager au psg maintenant
que messi est arrivé d'en être dans les
autres rumeurs c'était relativement
calme ça se tourner plutôt vers les
départs comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
marouane cardy peut-être pablo sarabia
teelock erreur jackson layvin kurzawa
tout on n'avait pas encore parlé
aujourd'hui le psg n'a pas l'air parti
pour recruter encore d'autres joueurs
tout cas une question de guy gazzo
comparée du ballon d'or de messi mais ce
que messi peut faire gagner ballon d'or
à neymar peut être même map et ce qu'il
reste mais est ce que est ce que
justement grâce hassan hemmar peut avoir
six ans de mandat oui bien sûr c'est
tout à fait possible
maintenant on est mort comme je l'aï dit
en 2022 ce que l'objectif ça serait
plutôt se tourner vers 2022 je pense pas
qu'on parle de cette année et en 2022
encore une fois il y aura la coupe du
monde en fin d'année est donc juste
avant la remise du trophée c'est quelque
chose qui peut peser très lourd je sais
pas comment vont s'organiser les voiles
j'imagine qu'ils vont quand même faire
en sorte que ça se déroule après la
coupe du monde ça serait un peu bête
sinon
c'est forcément quelque chose où le
joueur qui va briller avec son pays il
va avoir en plus le momentum il va
mettre toutes les chances de son côté
maintenant mais s'il peut le ramener la
ligue des champions au psg à partir de
là on verra un peu qui sort du lot qui
brille le plus mais marek bape et
ils ont un petit peu plus de chance
peut-être de gagner un ballon dans tout
cas de gagner la ligue des champions qui
leur permet de gagner le ballon d'or
ensuite effectivement et ben écoutez
merci beaucoup à vous tous de le voir
steevy merci sébastien pour se pose pour
toutes ces analyses on est resté en live
un peu plus d'une heure et demie c'était
vraiment très intéressant on a tous
suivi on vous invite à revoir ce live si
vous voulez revivre la la conférence de
presse de lionel messi et on se dit à
bientôt pour un nouveau live sur fear
alive